welcome to this video playing p.m. got
poon this is the guy always plays the
old Indian yes yes I ok no it just falls
into I Kings in it now yeah it's
interesting interesting move water that
Ernie d6 ok 92 f 5 f3 Bishop h6 might be
interesting because of Queen edge for
check I have ideas like h4 h5 not sure
how good down more it's a bit unsure how
to play this this type of position
that's also g4 as an interesting move ok
let's go G for toys osf my doubts how
exactly to do it G for each form just 92
this isn't particularly great for black
Wow but still not entirely clear what
the best way to proceed is so H for
hmm what does I mean what does blacks
point here
g5 and then aged five it's just
fantastic from what
yeah this Bishop is some not really bad
it's not the classically bad bishop but
I'd like to get my queen out also to h3
h4 something like that okay that's got
some tactic here I don't believe it
takes Knight eggs yeah what a nice
coincidental tactic okay so let's that
see him if i'm going to h 4f four takes
on g6 check on age 7 and rogue age 6
it's not really winning unfortunately
queen h 4f four h6 takes only three
takes on g7 however this is probably
winning okay not the only line but
this is trapped and this is why I mean
you can take on I don't know you will
get this no matter what is what I'm
trying the same so it's not that like
I'm winning simply if he takes on e3 and
I take on g7 takes on d to King f1 you
just went back which I completely forgot
about I completely forgot about this
move yeah the funny thing is his
position is so awful still with these
pieces that it's not entirely clear even
though it was completely unnecessary of
course to to to allow this stuff to
happen hmm yeah he will take them I
wonder what the best way is to force
them to do some maybe connect connect
rooks
Gabi should reforms bad this position
before Bishop divorce is basically
strategically winning for white not more
not less but Bishop g4 probably just has
a bad timing because of this some just
this weird night f6 resource so let's
see how to do this I wonder if if a
queen trade is actually an idea I mean
it is basically playing without the
bishop iam you know it's very weird but
maybe it is not easily putting pressure
on 1g5 so I wonder what taking on c5 a
stupid
it's rook f3m move basically forcing the
rook trade maybe I'm just taking too
much time here time warning just taking
too much time I a snide f6 and probably
you can pick up the h6 pawn this is
probably the real problem ultimately
they're all this self that's just a
comparable very comparable idea
want to put it on g5 trying to get play
against age 7
you cannot easily play b5 here or take a
couple of times and then check on the
7th so f1 a move no probably not
really not sure if I can do something
here or not Nyjah for maybe I can
threaten before it's got 85 now if I
broke everyone it still cannot go naija
for
it surprises me it feels very risky but
maybe I'm wrong I mean I don't have much
time to evaluate it
but it looks very very annoying from
Wagner 496 j so who h1s there I can
check me there it runs into check
check check check check no wow okay you
can just promote now white resigns yeah
that was I mean around TM I'm just
winning again but I didn't I screwed it
up I simply screw it up how to win now
who gave one winsome the IDA dick must
be winning I've got two passes there and
all his pieces are crap yeah but I
thought I played that well outside I
really lost the threat here with kings
before it still Windsor knot C 3 wins
but i really i really had Ted no no kind
of plan down yeah it was a very very
strange very strange game the thing is
that I mean blacks opening play is
completely it's totally off I just have
to avoid Bishop g4 him after which yes
is this wacky f5 move I mean it's it's
very obvious how bad blacks position is
he cannot move any of his pieces and
white space advantage is overwhelming
the engine gives what does it give queen
bee three and plus 1.6 sure yeah I mean
look like has nothing that you can do
what is he doing that would be a tour so
I castle long and a double on the edge
file it's just a disaster and he s this
wacky f5 move that somehow yeah
miraculously works I didn't see it I
didn't see it simply the engine actually
says that this wins for white but I
didn't see
here because of this is this resource
okay why even canceling long here yeah
well this is t 94 g6 and black explode
them okay i just saw this idea because i
already overlooked bishop h8 yeah very
simply that's really bad badly played
long castles are still what is the end
up giving 0 I don't know difficult to
trust the computer that it sometimes
underestimate those slowish text when
one side has very bad pieces yeah and
here well I'm a piece down but the
position is not that that easy he
immediately am returned stuff here with
Bishop f6 can just probably not so bad
but now he played it I think to
ambitiously with routledge aid and we
had stuff after a five wide wins but I
couldn't I couldn't put him away I
really couldn't yeah this is right even
this is given by the computer but now i
am now I'm completely losing the thread
here Butchie one I simply didn't see a
movie him I wanted to go look f1 yes and
then I spotted the fork and then I went
rogue g1 which has no particular purpose
this moved wins why does it win look b7
check is strong yes and he cannot take
the six because of the fork yeah this is
the best move according to the engine
and wins now this is winning him a very
very complicated stuff that wasn't
wasn't really really easy I'm actually
the most annoyed about the should reform
because this opening play should really
lead to a loss and
this f5 resource computer says this is
actually the right way to play a 5 wow I
am NOT very much trusting in the engine
there at least not after a short
calculation it gives this for example
here with the slight edge to white is
the is the initial evaluation and how
can this position be a slight edge to
white I mean this is completely crazy
and very very much impossible that
someone has a slight edge here it looks
very strange ok well thanks for watching